all right Ted well the long anticipated
drop a can of construction project
starts tomorrow night Mary Jane beliesa
is live now with those closures that
will be taking place she is joining us
from near the I-15 and deserted overpass
with more Denise this is a good reminder
for drivers to have an alternate route
plan because starting tomorrow night
drivers headed on the I-15 will not be
able to exit onto Tropicana in both
directions
Las Vegas local and college student Nyla
Marquez says she'll avoid that area for
now she says the closure combined with
the holiday this week already means
traffic it's been kind of rainy lately
too I feel like in certain
um like weather cases like that might be
that much harder for people to drive
through construction but also the rain
or like um you know just like heavy
traffic Justin Hopkins with the Nevada
Department of Transportation says the
project will include additional Lanes
along with pedestrian improvements and
better lighting he says this project
will come in three phases the first one
begins Tuesday night around 11 pm that's
when we close the South the ramps from
southbound I-15 to both East and
Westbound Tropicana
um make no mistake those are not
short-term closures of a day or two once
those close the 15 to
westbound Tropicana will be closed for
nine months and South 15 to eastbound
Tropicana that big flyover that takes
you down by the Excalibur that'll be
closed for approximately 18 months while
we do the complete takedown and
rebuilding of the Tropicana Avenue
Bridge Hopkins says unless you're
planning on heading to the strip it's
best to take a detour you're better off
just avoiding I-15 during the weekend of
that closure it's going to be heavy
traffic both North and southbound and
yes there's a detour but we know that
detour is going to get very crowded very
fast the freeway might be a company for
for some people just because you know
like there's a freeway everywhere so it
might be hard for people to navigate
through the side streets and then it
might create traffic there too so it's
like like where do I go
these Tropicana closures will remain in
place until January 30th reporting live
Mary Jane beliesa 8 News Now